oh hello this dude I used to play magic
so much me my brother and my dad got
into at the same time my dad kept going
he got to 17th in the state of Georgia
impossible into the second part it's
never going to happen I've been
wondering how hard it is to catch an
arrow I love a bow
hey I'm bother you for a second alright
come on ya doin join me what do you want
me to do is this how would you shoot
that at me try and hit me wait why are
you trying to shoot me good
what's that so clearly I'm an extremely
skilled in it but you guys think you can
do it they want to train with me I'm
down again Jake do you think you can
catch an arrow from Jake yeah I can try
[Music]
impossible into the second part it's
never going to happen so I'll be like
see if you can shoot it right there you
go if Raina would have gone that it
worked
[Music]
[Applause]
Wow I think she consider subscribing for
that I think you need to subscribe I
think we need to raise the stakes and we
need to have like a blindfolded King
behind you
and if arrow hits the king they die and
you're the bodyguard you just snatch it
out of the air you got trained to be the
ultimate soldier because this next scene
is sponsored by Magic the Gathering
this is the magic gather gathering this
is the gathering dude I used to play
magic so much I still got my old decks
man I got my deck - I'll be deck right
here
zombies this is my first this was my
very first magic deck ever fact me an
age did you start 10th edition is when I
started me my brother and my dad got
into at the same time along with a
couple friends I stopped playing like
two years later my dad kept going he got
to 17th in the state of Georgia he
competed like legit how does it compare
to the pokemon card game oh it's so much
better better it's like it's like chess
versus checkers like well you know yeah
yeah yeah it's like there's more to do
super fun way yes they're coming out
with a new thing oh yeah we're gonna
tell you all about it we have yet again
rented an awesome cabin out here in the
basically middle of nowhere and we are
filming Sam's spooky house aka turn off
[Music]
it's so important to start your day with
a healthy dose of protein we have three
nights to shoot this video here over the
course of those three nights we have
lots of things keeping the applications
with monsters and we have to figure out
what's the best order to shoot
everything in there's some technical
logistics we need to figure out that
each time you go to a new location is
always about your dreams and clashing
with reality so you know you go into it
imagining one thing and then you get to
your location generally everything
changes it's all about trying to adapt
that imagination that idea into what you
actually have before you the best way
possible yeah we're gonna figure that
out right now oh well hello this welcome
to The Adventures of Sam Gorski
ultimately directing is Thursday b-movie
yelling oh is that yeah we have to think
bigger
join us let me actually get to that this
is why seeing him like looking of the
like doing the shirt Oh what up son
night one in beautiful Ottawa California
Suns over there making fun of me
completely shooting in the dark over
night shoots you know we're looking at 6
p.m. to 2:30 to 3:00 a.m. nights for
three nights in a row there's a lot of
good sons on this shoots huh
so I'm looking forward to the shoot we
got Samson he's got a lot of skills Sam
son okay we also have Riley who's a
talented actress hi hello and I'm
playing Alyssa my name is Gabriel and
I'm playing Michael Gabriel Anthony Paul
yeah
if I sign though cat she's a talented
makeup artists effects artist so yeah
there's a lot of talented people as a
matter of fact can't cheer it right here
Jared sitar haunted son right here we
were talking about Jared earlier hmm and
we were saying you've been going from
the roof a lot yeah we're a little
concerned about that I can only do it
with like half a bottle of wine is
safety yeah yeah we're uh see the glaze
oh yeah okay all right we're about to
put gear on the roof Sam has instructed
this right that's correct
used to mentioned earlier or something
about g-string with that we'd be wearing
that that's for you I don't want to wear
that though yeah but it's for the
audience for them not for you I don't
want to wear a g-string though dude I
mean it's just you know it's like
flossing of Philly these two I'm a
horror fan so it's gonna be fun to like
dive into that genre for me for sure
I've never done horror either I've also
never brushed my hair like this either
too so that is a challenge I know but
many firsts first thing in the night
definitely a little nervous but once the
wheels of this shoot get goin it's gonna
be all good
I know our first scene here two lovers
on a couch and how do we make a look at
nights well check this out the entire
video right now is motivated by
moonlight the concept of moonlight being
the only source of light this is not
normal darkness this is movie darkness
and movie darkness is actually quite
bright so we need lights so well we want
to start with our actual true moonlight
which is effectively just one of those
aperture 120 DS that just
blast some nice hard rays right into the
room we have a little bit of a Heiser in
there to kick up some haze and mist
which will catch the light creating some
depth in the scene and also maybe some
light rays that look cool that's not all
because when you look into the camera
you'll see that all right the characters
are lit we have some layers all that
stuff but the room is still surrounded
in darkness so once again movie night
right what does that look like well
we've set up some of the the BH
proprietary lights what they call the
violas point is they're actually pretty
great because they're little and they
adapt to any color temperature and color
and hue shift we're using them to create
little splashes of light in the dark
areas of the room so that way when you
look at the scene you're not actually
looking at like blackness ever there's
always this kind of lift well the light
that actually likes the characters
spaces is gonna be a phone screen in
this scene
so we've cranked the red we've got some
good Sigma lenses on there and hopefully
the light sensitivity will carry us the
rest of the way let's be safe here let's
not relation these don't get anybody
hurt hey everything's set right now
and we can dive into it if everyone's
ready all right all right it's time to
up the stakes if you missed the arrow it
doesn't just hit a wall it hits a person
all right Chinchin to see who the king
is that's gonna stand there blindfolded
he'll let me go all right that's right
today's video is brought to you by our
sponsor Magic the Gathering guilds of
Ravnica the 79th expansion of Magic the
Gathering the game now where the guild
war imminent the Celestia Conclave one
of the guilds of Ravnica is preparing
their armies the corridor crew has
signed on to help them as artists and
scouts obviously because we're super
into archery no fooling around you gotta
catch this arrow we just have to do the
same thing we had last time red and stop
it like this
to defend our king listen if I die you
die too I said if I die you die too
no talk to you man
that's the log is a goner for sure
there you go I got you I got to go okay
save me I'm saying I want to shoot I
want to shoot that's it just like at any
moment this is gonna happen anywhere in
your body you're gonna die clinch I
don't need to do this I want Jake to
protect me right I don't trust either of
these two what we've
we really scared did I just let get off
this Wow slashing prices dude not even
nervous anymore
right there's all this - oh my god
now my king I get to execute you I think
that's only fair
King Joseph there's 16 your head is mine
hey gotcha King Joseph the 16 your head
will be in my possession
[Music]
Renne that was cruel Wow ice cold so
that's it I hope you enjoyed it remember
Magic the Gathering guilds of Ravnica is
on sale October 5th each guild has its
own unique style ideology and characters
the Celestia Conclave is one of the most
interesting which is why we wanted to do
something with it has powerful military
like aspects combined with almost hippie
like commune bods it's really
interesting also that are unique
ideology teaches that individuals must
be willing to perish so that the greater
good may survive kind of like I just did
right here
[Music]
yo if you see what man that'd be this is
that
historian occasion my glasses bees
anything bubbies
they see right through me lacy rectory
not to be big
yeah remember how that one went